One year ago today, here at this Westgate hotel,
I embarked on a life changing adventure.
As I pass on my crown as Mrs.
American, I am filled with gratitude and joy
to have been able to be a part of this journey.
What a year it has been. I'm deeply
and forever grateful for the unwavering support of my husband, Daniel,
and our children, Henry, Charles,
George, Francis,
Lois, Martha,
Mabel and flora.
Your love and encouragement has been my greatest strength.
I'm also so grateful to the Mrs.
American Organization, Elaine and Tana,
and my directors, Jackie and Jolie.
Their dedication has been instrumental in my journey
and I'm so thankful.
Another highlight of my year
was growing and giving birth to my daughter,
Miss Flora Joe. I was pregnant with her during the pageant,
and my due date was just two weeks before the Missus World pageant
in January. Flora was born January 2nd.
And 13 days after she was born,
we checked in to the Missus World pageant here in Las Vegas.
With our supportive family and community,
together, her and I,
we made it happen.
It was a sweet and tender experience that we will cherish forever.
Another cherished memory I hold forever
will be competing on the Missus World stage
while my father watched proudly.
He passed just two weeks after.
His memory continues to be a guiding light in my life
and I miss him everyday.
I know he's been my guardian angel the past Few months.
My reign has allowed me to shine a spotlight on the know Your Farmer,
know your food initiative,
emphasizing the importance of sustainable farming
and food chain diversity.
I love sharing our farm and our story with so many of you.
As I pass on the Crown, I celebrate the achievements,
but more importantly, the friendship this role has allowed me to make.
With all the love and gratitude,
Hannah Neelman, Mrs. American 2023.